we're also getting more music from you
this year expensive my new single and
you get to watch me cast the video
Madame video so great BTS you know it's
more than Eileen and going to come down
and visit man listen
oh you pull them baby happy to be down
there they stay down there like for a
long time they were watching and then
they were having their own moment sunset
you know doing their own there wait yeah
no I'm excited
me too I want to see it we haven't heard
any of this song so what's the vibe um
you know it's expensive to be Mike he's
sitting right over there did you come up
with any nude moves of Pat the puss part
two well listen you know here's
something you need to understand Pat the
puss was so organic but we have some
great new choreography on the way that I
think is and I know the casting of the
video is episode to see it nice there's
some intense splitting happening
you looked almost shocked well one girl
like elevated I don't know what this
chick like came up off the ground and
then it was impressive herself yes hope
she's okay she was great she got the job
okay there we go what it takes to
impress angel trick put the government
on the back yeah
[Music]